it's my honor to introduce to you dr.
Ian rawson
Thank You president Cohen for that very
gracious introduction and and thank you
for this opportunity to salute these
outstanding graduates it's it's a little
bit intimidating to look out here and to
see all of you who are graduating and
knowing that when you came here several
years ago probably every one of you was
the top student in your class or knew
who was but every now and then Leslie
will recognize this as a Copernican
inversion that sometimes it's possible
for us as teachers to learn from our
students and it's possible for us as
healthcare providers to learn from our
patients and that's an experience I
would like to share with you today as
president Cohen said I have the honor to
serve at Hope eat Albert Schweitzer in
our hospital which is three hours from
port-au-prince far out of the epicenter
of the earthquake zone not directly
affected we were somewhat dissociated
from reality because all the internal
telecommunications in the country
collapsed we had no cell phones no way
of communicating we didn't know the
extent of the problem in port-au-prince
it was late in the evening when the
first patient started to come in the
back of pickup trucks tap taps that
serve as public conveyances patients who
had been found by family members our
neighbors and placed on the door of the
ruined building and put into the back of
the pickup truck and driven out to the
hospital which at that time was one of
the few hospitals open in Haiti at least
to the area closest to the hospital to
the to the capital city and they came
one and two and three and four and then
many and still we had no idea of what
the extent of the damage was you knew
more about what was happening in haiti
than we did you had the advantage of the
helicopters flying over the capital he
had the advantage of Anderson Cooper
pointing reality to us yet one more time
and us we didn't know all we knew was
the reality of more and more patients
were coming we have a trauma system
where we can take care of mass
casualties maybe 30 patients at a time
if one of these tap taps that's fully
loaded tips over we went through that
protocol in about an hour and more and
more patients came with incredible
strength determination and even
creativity one of the young men who came
we went out to the truck to bring him in
to transform transfer him to a stretcher
to bring him into the hospital and
someone had wrapped around his right leg
pieces of cardboard that would hold his
leg stable pretty good first day don't
forget that trick and as we were putting
him on the stretcher was evident that
that wasn't the only place where he had
been hurt and he won lee was didn't want
to share any of the pain in Haiti when
you see somebody you must greet them
he's young yay how are you I asked poppy
mo I'm not too bad and here he expressed
the strength the determination he had no
idea where he was he had no idea what he
had actually lost he knew that he was in
pain and he hoped that this would be
better unbalanced he said it's not too
bad as we started to move people out of
the small triage area into a larger
holding area and started to find out
where to put all these people and
finding out that we our 80 beds were
used immediately and we went to every
house on the campus and just took beds
out of people's out of people's rooms
and put them up in the hospital and then
sent to town to buy some more the
logistics were astounding and in the
emergency area the expanded emergency
area we were running almost in boolean
motion to get IV lines to take people to
the laboratory or to the x-ray and all
of a sudden that occurred to me that it
was so quiet think about a television
program about a scene in emergency room
and people are running around and shout
dr. any additional fast at and my
husband my husband turn off the sound
and that's what it was like for us we
were moving or fast but we weren't
making any noise because the patients
were not making any noise it's almost as
though we automatically realized that we
must respect the quiet that they had the
reserve and the strength we started to
sort people around and take them down
the halls to be ready to go into the
operating room to operating rooms
operating virtually 24 hours a day all
of our permanent doctors are Haitian all
of our permanent nurses are Haitian and
that's who was there when the earthquake
quit and that's who is there for several
weeks thereafter and I was going down
one of the halls and somebody I had
passed frequently an older woman she
waved me over being probably don't come
I want to talk to you okay we saw Julian
this hurts me and she points to her leg
and on her leg was an x-ray because he
was one of the ones next in line for the
operating room so I looked at the x-ray
and then I had to turn it so it was
between me and her face because I didn't
want her to see what my reaction to the
x-ray was and I put it down I said yes
in kinase andouille oh I know that hurts
you scusi madam we don't have anything
we ran out of all of our antibiotics we
ran out of all of our analgesics within
five days we keep a 30-day supply that's
how big the demand was and she looked up
to me with a smile and almost as though
she was comforting me because she'd seen
me going by hundreds of times in the
several days and she says we mikoni I
know perseverance perseverance that's
what it's going to take to get through
this that's what it's going to take her
to get through this terrible injury she
has to wait until it's her turn to go to
the operating room that's what it's
going to take all of us to get through
this people in Haiti have had a tough
life they've had to persevere
it's only with perseverance perseverance
that they're able to continue and to
thrive in the mornings when we would go
around the hospital and see how people
were overnight people had recognized
that there were going to be there at the
hospital for several days and family
members had brought them radios so in
the morning there's a popular program
where they play hymns at seven o'clock
in the morning and somebody in this
large waiting room area that we had had
put on the radio and had the hymns and
very quietly so as not to disturb
anybody but the woman who had the radio
was singing with it and other people
were singing and that other people were
singing and all around the room they
were singing quietly again not to
disturb people who had yet woken up not
everybody in Haiti is Christian but
everybody was singing because everyone
recognized the power of song to raise
your voice to an unknown spirit perhaps
in supplication perhaps in thanks but
commuting together from many faiths at
the same time but seeking and finding
strength in the possibility of communing
together with some higher force that
might help them through this to join
their perseverance with hope after
several weeks we began to see the tide
recede we were able to transfer patients
out of the hospital to an uncertain
future in an American Hospital we write
on a chart transfer home we just wrote
transfer because we didn't know whether
these people had homes and many of them
did not have homes to go back to but we
began to see the patterns emerging and
we began to notice in the few moments we
had to talk together the large number of
patients who had come out to us with
traumatic amputation and the several
that we had had to perform amputations
on either due to the trauma or because
of the possibility of infections and a
wonderful thing happened we had the
opportunity to start a prosthetic
service to be able to give people who
had
lost an arm or a leg some new mechanism
to be mobile to be active and after
several weeks we had collected a large
number of patients and we had arranged
some houses in a village where they
could live as they're waiting and the
technicians we would go over and they
would explain the mechanism of the
complex knee and the complex foot and
the feet are wonderfully designed they
have a middle plate a narrow metal plate
under them and it's an energy
transferring plate so think as you put
fat your foot down and roll forward as
you're walking forward and your toes
kick up to carry you forward don't try
that now your time is coming but the
it's what it magically it propels you
forward we're explaining this to people
and two of the people we enjoy talking
to so much a young girl with a beatific
flawed but smile and her good friend
they had met at the hospital and they
had bonded almost as sisters and we were
explaining this and she had taken a few
dance lessons and they were always
moving gracefully whenever the radio was
playing in the small village she said
yes that looks good to me that's a great
idea the next day she and her friend
came and they were the first ones to
receive their new legs and she was first
and they fitted the leg and she walked
on the parallel bars and because she was
graceful he said now later you can walk
outside the bar she said that's okay I
can do it and turned around and walked
around and all the doctors the nurses
the physical therapists were there
taking her picture and cheering her on
and she got to the end and gave us all
her her patent and beautiful smile and
then her friend was getting her likes
everybody else went down to be with her
and to cheer her on and to take her pack
her pictures so she went back to the
parallel bars and she walked out she
held on with her left hand and stood
there for a moment then rose up on
tiptoe and struck a pose again
with her most beatific smile and only a
few of us saw that but those who did
learn from her the power of perseverance
the power of hope a young girl who had
lost almost everything her family her
home her leg but she knew where she was
going and she knew how she could carry
forward so from our patients at our
Hospital in Haiti who are our teachers
and me I congratulate all of you for
what you've learned from your teachers
wish you Godspeed motions good luck
Missy unpeeled thank you very much